보스턴다님에서도 물구나무석이 해서 성능들을 입증을 했다.
짜란다 짜란다.
아니 근데 물구나무 선거는 저게 위가 다리고 아래가 파리하고 정의를 하니까 우리가 보기에 물구나무석지.
현대차 팔고 나서 지금 상당히 까칠하셨는데.
냉철해졌어요.
주주일 때는 이런 거 안 궁금해하더니.
한번 내려왔다 다시 가시던가.
네 이분은 유진투자증권의 양승윤 연구원님.
안녕하십니까.
아유 연구원님 안녕하십니까.
네 안녕하세요.
지난번 방산형으로 조회수가 장난 아니에요.
아 그래서 한번 또 달달해서 모셨군요.
달달해서 모셨는데 제가 개인적으로 로봇을 너무 관심이 많은데 로봇 하면 딱 이분밖에 생각이 안 나더라고요.
그래서 제가 어렵사리 또 모시게 되었습니다.
그래서 본인 주식 물어보려고 모셨다는 거네요 결국.
겸사 겸사.
아 겸사 겸사.
오늘 로봇 어떤 얘기가 있죠?
사실 로봇주가 최근에 좀 반등을 계속 하고 있거든요.
핸드차도 말씀해주셨지만 전체적으로 섹터가 올라오고 있는데.
제가 좀 엉때리고 있었어요.
한 6개월 전에 자료를 쓰고 나서 크게 바뀌는 거 없겠지 생각을 하고 있었었는데.
그 사이에 뉴스 플로우나 이런 것들 쌓여가는 거 보면 조금 변화들이 심상치 않다라고 생각을 해서.
시작된 변화 이런 타이틀로 자료를 써봤다라고 보시면 될 것 같고.
오 좋습니다.
오늘 쭉 어떤 흐름들이 있는지 좋은 이야기도 하고 안 좋은 이야기도 같이 드리는.
안 좋은 이야기도 있어요?
이제 냉정하게.
냉정하게.
좋아요.
냉정히 필요합니다.
일단은 먼저 이제 개황부터.
여기 위에 보시면 이게 로봇 우리나라 신제품.
총 변동입니다.
22년부터 해서 25년까지 쭉 올라가는 거 보실 수가 있고.
좀 보면서 로봇 시장이 어떻게 흘러왔는지를 랩업을 드리면 좋을 것 같은데.
일단 결론 23년도부터 올라가기 시작을 했다.
이때 무슨 일이 있었냐.
삼성전자가 레인보우 로보틱스를 투자를 했다.
맞아.
그래서 이제 시장에서는 우리나라에서 제일 잘 나가는 삼성전자가 로봇한 된다 하면서 시장 기대감들이 폭발을 23년도에는 했었었고요.
맞아요.
그런데 24년도에 보면 또 이제 좋지 않습니다.
흘러내려요.
무슨 일이냐라고 하면.
이 로봇은 24년도를 기점으로 해서 시장이 바뀌었습니다.
AI 쪽으로 시장이 완전히 바뀌었어요.
맞아요.
로봇도 인지판단 수행 이 세 가지를 다 자율적으로 하는 기계인데.
사실 그 전에 로봇들은 인지판단에 대한 영역이 매우 매우 부족했습니다.
그래서 이제 이거 자율 로봇 할 수 있겠냐.
이렇게 생각을 했던 거지만 22년도에 채TPT 나오고.
그다음에 트랜스포머 기반으로 막 GPT-3, GPT-4 업그레이드가 되면서.
이 AI의 바람이 이제는 물리 영역까지 위치기 시작을 하면서.
이제는 이 정도 AI 발전하면.
휴먼웨이드.
휴먼웨이드든 피지컬 AI는 할 수 있다라고 생각을 하셨던 거고.
이제 우리나라 못했으니까 좀 빠졌던 건데.
25년도에는 그러거나 말거나 올라갔거든요.
그런데 이제 그런 건 알겠고.
이제 앞으로가 중요하고.
지금까지 뭐 어떻게 되는지가 중요한 건데.
일단 올해도 많이 올랐다.
이거 올해 오른쪽 상단 차트 보시면.
1번 현대차 CES.
이때부터 해서 주가가 올라갔고.
갑자기 또 여기서 코스닥 부양책이 나오면서.
한 번 더 점프업을 하면서 주가가 올라갔다가.
이후에는 좀 모멘텀들이 소멸되면서 깨졌어요.
그런데 지금 8번 보시면.
지금 다시 올라가고 있는데.
지금 올라가고 있는 물론 여러 요인들이 있습니다.
물론 이게 제가 애널리스트로서 굉장히 좀 쪽팔린 이야기이기도 한데.
왜 오르냐고 물어봤을 때.
사실 이제 삼전파업 때문이라고 하기에는 좀.
삼전파업 때문에 로봇시총이 올라가요?
이게 굉장히 쪽팔린.
너무 극장식.
논리 아닙니까? 논리가.
긍정노조. 긍정노조.
아니.
적응을 해야 됩니다.
시장이 왜 움직이는지를 생각하다 보면.
그럴 수밖에 없었다.
맞지.
이게 맞지.
맞아요?
이게 맞는 것 같아요.
사실 삼성전자가 22년대부터 해서.
2030년도에는 약간 무인화 공장을 하겠다라고 계속 이야기를 했었었고.
물론 이걸 이제 사람을 가라앉는다 이런 이야기는 아니에요.
조심스럽지만.
어쨌든 자동화라고 하는 거는 피할 수 없는 바람이다라고 하면서.
시장에서 다시 로봇을 좀 봐야겠다라고 생각을 하셨던 것 같고.
맞습니다.
그 타이밍에 갑자기 엔비디아에서 메디슨 황이 한국에 와가지고 로봇 이야기를 하고.
구글의 딥마인드의 데이비드 하사비스 CEO가 와서 현대차 만나고.
로봇 이야기를 하니까.
AI 잘하고 소프트웨어 잘하는 친구들이 한국을 왜 잡고 오지 생각해보면.
한국은 또 뭘 잘하냐 했을 때 하드웨어 이런 걸 또 잘하니까.
그런 관점에서 협업을 할 수 있지 않을까라는 기대감이 살짝 또 붙었고.
그리고 또 이제 양산형 아틀라스가 움직였어요.
이게 1월달 CES에는 멍청하게 하라고는 안 되지만 가만히 서 있었거든요.
가만히.
실제로 움직이는 영상이 공개가 되었습니다.
움직인다라고 하는 게 매우 중요한 거고.
사실 뒤에서도 말씀드리겠지만.
결국 양산형 로봇이라 그래서 이거 좀 퀄리티가 떨어지지 않을까?
이거 제대로 움직이기나 할까?
이런 의문들이 많으셨을 텐데.
물고 나무서기하고 팔굽합하기 같은 거 하고 하는 게.
예전에 아틀라스가 항상 해왔던 거예요.
옛날 구형 아틀라스, 신형 아틀라스, 기본 양산형 아틀라스.
우리가 구동 방식을 전기로 바꿔도.
아니면 우리가 액취에이터를 조금 양산형 버전으로 바꿔도.
우린 똑같은 움직임을 구현할 수 있다는 기술력에 대해서 보여줬던 거기 때문에.
저는 결코 나쁘지 않았다.
라고 생각을 해서 여러 가지 기대감들이 더해지면서 주가 강세가 나오고 있는 그런 상황이고.
그래서 제가 오늘 좀 말씀을 드리고 싶었던 건 일단 로봇은 쉽게 죽지 않는다.
그러니까 모멘텀이 올라갔다가 꺾이는 순간들도 있지만.
로봇은 구조적인 변화의 흐름이기 때문에 사실 저희는 항상 좀 빠질 때마다 관심을 가져야 된다.
그리고 종목들이 살짝 질릴 수는 있긴 하지만 새로운 기업들이 또 들어오기 때문에.
시장 환기도 계속 될 거다.
이런 내용들을 말씀을 드립니다.
오른쪽 하단 차트 보시면.
사실 중요한 게 로봇은 제가 이제 약간 시장의 그 흐름들을 잘 따라가야 된다 말씀을 드렸는데.
모멘텀 기반으로 해서 트레이딩이 또 많이 되고 있는 섹터이기도 해요.
그래서 무슨 모멘텀이 있는지를 봐야 되는데.
또 오른쪽 하단에 좀 저희가 알고 있는 걸 다 정리를 드렸습니다.
이제 지나간 것들은 회색으로 표기를 해놨고.
그리고 이제 앞으로 나올 요것도 특히 주목해서 봐야 되는 거를 파란색으로 해놨는데.
보시면 이제 테슬라가 사실 아직 안 움직였거든요.
테슬라가 원래 1분기 때 옵티머스 공개한다고 해놓고.
맞아요.
딜레이가 됐어요.
근데 얘네가 못해서 딜레이가.
됐느냐라고 하면 그거는 아닌 거고.
일단 지금 이미 듀데이 최종 기한은 정해져 있습니다.
7월달, 8월달부터 양산을 할 거예요.
진짜 준비됐어요 근데?
준비를 하고 있습니다.
거의 다 됐고.
지난주에는 또 모델 S 그리고 모델 X라인을 폐쇄를 하고 로봇으로 바꾼다고 이야기를 했거든요.
최종 그 차량들이 출구화가 되면서 이제 세리머니까지 했기 때문에.
이제 라인 폐쇄하고 전환을 하는 거예요.
그래서 이거는 뭐 할 수밖에 없고 해야만 하는 상황들이고.
그럼 테슬라 주가는 뭐 위든 아래든 움직이겠네요.
움직일 거라고 생각을 합니다.
제일 기대하는 건 삼성이.
삼성이 아직 아무 이야기가 없었어요.
레인보우 로보틱스는 주가는 겁나 뛰는데 그래서 뭔 로봇을 만드는지는 모르겠는 거예요.
레인보우 로보틱스는 지금 이제 주로 만들고 계시는 게 이동형 양팔 로봇.
약간 휴머노이드인데 약간 세미 휴머노이드.
약간 상반심한 사람의 형체이고 다리는 없는 그런 형태의 로봇으로 가고 계시는데.
사실 레인보우 로보틱스의 로봇도 중요하지만 저는 그냥 삼성이 만드는 로봇이 중요하다고 생각을 해요.
4분기에 공개가 됩니까?
뭐 기대를 합니다.
작년도에 삼성 레인보우 로보틱스의 창업주이신 오준호 박사님을 삼성에서 데리고 가셨거든요.
거기서 미래로봇 추진단이라는 걸 만들고 거기 단장님으로 모셔갔는데 오 박사님 오시고 나서 기술 수준이 많이 올라왔고
글로벌 리딩하는 기업들에 따라갈 수 있는 기술 기반들을 마련했다고 이야기를 했는데.
기대된다.
사실 삼성이라고 하는 회사가 대단히 보수적인 회사잖아요.
이렇게 잘 이야기를 안 하실 텐데 어느 정도 디벨롭이 되고 있는 상황이지 않을까.
그런데 이 상황들을 보니까 지금 유니트리 도 상장하셨잖아요.
그리고 삼성 로봇도 공개되면 현대차 주가 떨어질 것 같은데.
사실 그 부분들은 이제 또 저희가 고려를 해야 되는 부분들이 맞아요.
저는 이제 섹터로 봤을 때 현대차가 잘해주면 로봇도 가니까 어차피 좋은 거고 삼성이 잘해줘도 가는 거니까 좋으니까.
개인적으로는 로봇 섹터 일단은 좋다.
그런데 개별 현대차 그룹이라든지 주가 관점에서는 변화가 있을 수 있다는 내용이고.
사실 닌이님께서 되게 잘 짚어주신 게 만약에 9월에 중국 유니트리가 상장을 하면 잘하고 돈도 많이 벌거든요.
거의 4천억 원에다가 영업이익률로는 일회성 빼면 거의 40%까지도 영업이익률을 기록을 하는 회사여서.
되게 못 팔아요 유니트리는.
휴머노이드랑 사족보행 로봇을 팝니다.
사족보행? 어디에 쓰이는 거예요?
사실 이것도 되게 재밌는 게 시장에서는 이게 산업 현장에서 당장이라도 뭔가 투입되는 것처럼 이야기를 하시지만.
사실 지금 90%는 R&D용으로 들어가고 있어서 약간 개발자분들이나 대학이나 연구센터 이런 데서 많이 쓰고 계셔서.
그런데 4천억이나 팔았어요?
중국이 워낙 시장이 커가지고.
중국에는 연구센터만 거의 열몇 개가 있습니다.
그런데 시가총액이 10조로 올라올 거거든요.
그런데 지금 우리나라 기업들이나 글로벌 기업들 비교해서 보면 4천억씩이나 하고 글로벌 1등인데 휴머노이드 출하대수로는 이 회사가 들어오면 조금 이 회사를 더 사야 되는 거 아니냐.
이런 의견들도 있을 수 있어서 글로벌 관점에서 봤을 때는 오히려 유니트리 로보틱스에 대한 롱 포지션이 잡히고 한국이나 다른 국가들은 또 안 좋은 포지션이 잡힐 수 있는 부분들은 리스크다.
그래서 그런 것들을 좀 잘 보면서 트래킹을 하면서 이 모멘텀들 굉장히 좀 기민하게 저희가 대응을 해야죠.
이렇게 생각을 하고 있습니다.
7페이지는 사실 제가 이 부분은 전문가가 아니지만 사실 개인 투자자분들 입장에서는 ETF 투자도 많이 하실 텐데 로봇 쪽에서 ETF가 벌써 한 15개까지 늘어났어요.
요즘에 계속 생겨요.
계속 생기고 또 잘 돼요.
그러다 보니까 이게 이제 수급으로 또 뒷받침되는 부분들이 있거든요.
지금 코스닥 ETF는 제가 이렇게 써놨지만 그 다음 페이지 보시면 로봇 ETF AUM 왼쪽 상단에 보시면 엄청나게 늘어났고.
그리고 오른쪽 상단에 연초 들어와서.
1월부터 4월까지 이 ETF 쪽으로 순유인만 거의 1.3조 원이 들어와 있는 상황이어서 결국 거기 안에 들어가 있는 구성 종목들의 기계적으로 또 매수수가 들어오는 거니까 ETF를 사면.
이 부분들이 좀 주가에 대한 하방을 지지해 줄 수 있는 포인트가 되었다.
이제 이런 패시브 수급들이 들어오면 조금 그래도 투자자분들 입장에서 안정적으로 느끼실 수 있는 게 하방으로 뒷받침될 수 있는 부분들은 플러스 포인트다 이렇게 생각합니다.
로봇 ETF라고 돼 있는데 제가 구성 종목을 보니까 코덱스 로봇 액티브에 삼성전자가 10% 들어있고 SK인의 하이닉스가 4% 들어있어요.
삼성전자가 10% 들어있고 SK인의 하이닉스가 4.8% 들어있거든요.
삼성전자가 앞으로 로봇 산다곤 하지만 너무 좀 앞서서 반도체 기업들 겨운 거 아닌가요?
예리했어.
엄청 예리하시고 사실 저도 그런 생각을 합니다.
파들파들 떨리고 있는데 좋은 부분들은 선택지가 많아졌어요.
일단은 코덱스도 있고 라이드도 있고 타이거도 있고 하나라도 있고 에이스도 있는데 사실 지금 이 다섯 개를 다 보시면 조금 달라요.
특히 이제 맨 오른쪽에 이 에이스 K 휴머노이드 로봇 산업을 보시면 사실 여기 또 이제 어마무시하게 비중을 실어놓으셨죠.
사실 여기 또 이제 어마무시하게 비중을 실어놓으셨죠.
로보티즈에 20% 심으시고.
제가 저거 갖고 있어요. 에이스 휴머노이드.
그래서 약간 이 투자자분들이 보셨을 때 나는 조금 이제 안정적으로 대형주랑 섞어서 가고 싶다 하시면 코덱스 이런 걸 선택하실 수 있는 거고
그게 아니라 좀 로봇 쪽에 진짜 필요한 기업들의 익스포저를 가져가고 싶다 하시면 에이스를 사시는 거고.
종목 잘 봐야겠다.
사실 그래서 구성 종목 저 항상 보시라고 말씀드리거든요.
그래서 이렇게 좀 가지고 왔고 약간 이런 차별점들이 있는데 여기로 이제 수급들이 들어오면서 그래도 이제 탑10 안에 들어있는 기업들에 대해서는 좋은 부분들이 있다.
그리고 이제 이어집니다.
이어서 IPO 이야기도 드려야 되는데 오늘 이제 코스모로보틱스가 따따상을 갔던 것 같아요.
굉장히 잘 갔었는데 그러니까 제가 다른 섹터 IPO는 잘 모르겠어요.
근데 로봇 IPO를 제가 오랫동안 봤을 때 느낀 거는 IPO가 잘 되려면 섹터 분위기가 좋아야 됩니다.
섹터 분위기 좋을 때 뭐 따따상 가고 따상 가고 하는 거고 섹터 분위기가 안 좋을 때는 이제 안 좋습니다.
여기 보시면은 오른쪽 상단에 이제 상장 당일 시초가 형성들을 보시면은 시장 좋았던 23년도에는 굉장히 좋았어요.
근데 이제 안 좋았던 24년도에는 이제 슬픈.
그렇지.
성과들이 있었고 작년부터는 다시 또 이제 좋아지고 있는 상황이어서 일단 결론 지금 상황은 좋으니까 이제 이번에 들어온 IPO들은 다 아주 수익성 수익률이나 흥행 자체는 성공할 수 있는 부분들을 이제 이야기를 드리고 있고 이제 뭐 10페이지에 보시면 제가 21년도 레인보우부터 해서 상장했던 기업들을 다 정리를 드리고 있는데 이걸 보자 이런 게 아니라 오른쪽에 보시면 여기 제가 표시하는 아우로보틱스라고 하는 회사가 있는데 이 회사가 25년도 5월달에 상장을 했거든요.
근데 그 이후로 1년 동안 로봇 IPO가 없었어요.
왜죠?
사실 신청했던 회사가 없었던 것 같고 뭐 신청을 했다가 이제 반려되기도 하고 조금 철회했던 회사들도 있어가지고 약간 명맥이 끊겨 있었었는데 이제 중요한 건 1년 만에 이제 코스모로보틱스 들어오면서 시작을 했고 그리고 이제 여기서 끝나는 게 아니라 뭐 계속된다.
앞으로 예정되어 있는 게 많아요?
엄청나게 많아요.
여기 보시면 코스모로보틱스 뭐 빅웨이브로보틱스 뭐 모비어스 뭐 HD 현대 로보틱스는 조금 이제 중복 상장에 대한 이야기들 때문에 어려우실 수도 있는 거고 새로운 기업들이 많이 들어와요.
보시면 이제 뭐 빅웨이브로보틱스는 약간 플랫폼.
플랫폼 성격을 가지고 있는 좀 약간 좀 이해하기 어려우실 수도 있지만 새로운 유형의 로봇 그리고 이제 에이딘 로보틱스 같은 경우는 촉각 센서를 하는 센서 그리고 테솔로는 로봇에서 제일 중요한 손 그리고 기타 업으로 해가지고 저희가 뭐 홀리데이 로보틱스 리얼월드 위로보틱스 써놨지만 뭐 휴머노이드 피지컬 AI 완전 진짜 범용 AI를 하는 회사들까지 줄줄이 이제 저희가 상장을 할 거여서 제가 이제 투자자분들께 항상 이야기 드리는 거는 올해까지는 뭐 그 동안에 좋았던 기업들이 계속 좋을 수 있다.
근데 내년도에는 주도하는 종목이 바뀔 수도 있다.
라고 이제 이야기도 드리고 있고 그리고 또 이제 로봇 기업들이 보통 상장을 하면은 한 2천억 3천억 레벨로 상장을 하는데 지금 로봇 기업들 아까 보셨던 것처럼 다 5천억 1조 이렇게 캡이 형성이 되어 있어서 일단은 이제 그 캡 관점에서 봤을 때는 좀 이제 캐치업할 수 있는 포인트들이 있기 때문에 시장에서 되게 기다리고 또 이제 선호하시는 부분들도 있지 않겠나.
그래서 IPO 시장도 재밌어질 테니까 좀 관심을 가시자.
아니 테솔로는 테슬라랑 이름이 뭔가.
아니 뭐 이름 갖고 그래.
그렇게 치면 저기 리얼월드도 계시네.
이름 잘 지셨네.
확실히 좀.
피지컬 AI니까 리얼월드다.
미래스럽긴 하다.
약간 조금 이제 MG 느낌?
우리나라가 로봇 기업이 생각보다 많이 IPO가 대기하고 있는데요.
거의 20개가 지금.
엄청 많습니다.
로봇은 항상 뭐 약간 PBR 뭐 이런 것도 막 너무 높고 좀 거품이 있다 뭐 이런 얘기를 또 하는 사람도 있으니까 이게 진짜인지 뻥튀기인지.
자네가 걱정할 정도면 상당히 걱정되는 데 또군요.
자네가 보통 그런 걱정 잘 안 하는 분인데.
네.
잘 모르니까.
걱정하시는 거 같은데.
로봇이 이제 그런 섹터라고 보통 많이 생각을 하셔가지고 한국뿐만 아니라 글로벌로 똑같습니다.
야 이거 휴머노이드가 양산한다고 하는데 진짜 하는 거 맞냐.
그게 긴가맨가 하는 거야.
거기에 대해서 조금씩 말씀을 한번 드려보면 제가 이제 숫자로 보이기 시작하는 양산 이렇게 써놨는데 일단 뭐 휴머노이드 일단 만들고 보자.
일단 제가 원천 차단을 했어요.
휴머노이드 만들어서 어디다 써 라는 질문을 원천 차단을 한 건데 로봇 기업들이 약간 그렇게 가고 있습니다.
야 그거 수요 생각까지 하면은 이 로봇 애초에 못 만드니까 일단 찍어내고.
응.
양산하면서 가격 싸게 만들고 양산성 확인하고 약간 이러고 이제 시작을 해보자 이제 이런 방향성으로 가고 있어서 일단 이제 양산기에는 들어갔다라는 내용들을 좀 말씀을 드릴 거고요.
이제 왼쪽 하단 차트 보시면 이제 주요 휴머노이드 기업들이 있습니다.
여기 좀 작긴 한데.
유니트리.
유니트리 뭐 에즈봇 유비텍 많이 들어보셨을 중국 기업들부터 해가지고 뭐 테슬라 BD 뭐 피규어 AI 원엑스까지 해서 있는데 이 회사들이 지금 이제 어느 정도 캐파들을 다 공개를 하고 있어요.
작년도에는 중국 기업들 막 1,000대에서 5,000대.
올해는 이제 모든 기업들이 다 1만 대 이상으로 캐파를 구축을 하고 있습니다.
그리고 2030년대에는 뭐 10만 대에서 100만 대 이렇게.
테슬라 100만 대 뭐냐.
근데 이게 약간 27, 28, 29년 약간 공백이에요.
아마 제 생각은 그래요.
그러니까 올해 이제 1만 대씩 캐파 만들어서 찍어내면서 테스트 파일럿 돌려보고 이렇게 고도화를 시켜서 30년대부터 진짜 매스 프로덕션 양산 들어가겠다라는 이야기로 이제 생각을 하고 있고.
너무 좋다.
웅장해진다.
장표의 사진을 보시면은 이제 왼쪽에 있는 게 테슬라의 프리먼트 공장입니다.
그래서 막 모델 Y도 만들고.
뭐 S도 만들고.
막 이랬던 이제 공장이고 여기서 이제 휴머네이드 찍어낸다라는 이야기고.
근데 오른쪽에 보시면은 이제 원엑스라고 하는 회사가 있고요.
그리고 피규어라고 하는 회사가 있고.
어질리티라고 하는 회사들이 있는데 이 회사들이 진짜 양산하는 거냐 되게 궁금해하실 수도 있는데 일단 공장은 있습니다.
6,000평 7,000평 그래서 연간 뭐 1만 대 10만 대 캐파를 구축을 하고 계시는 상황들이고요.
일단 공장이 있다 첫 번째 확인을 했고요.
그리고 그 공장이 진짜 돌아가고 있는지를 봐야 되는데.
지지난주에 영상들이 다 나왔어요.
마침 제가 이제 자료를 써야지 했던 그 찰나에 이 영상들이 다 공개가 돼가지고 뭐 피규어 AI 양산 형장 그리고 원엑스 테크놀로지스도 이렇게 양산을 하고 있어서 공장이 이제 바쁘게 돌아가고 있는 것들도 다 확인을 했다.
뭐 테슬라인데 테슬라도 하고 있어요.
하고 있어?
제가 이제 생각했던 거는 야 이거 가지고 뭐 양산이냐 하실 수도 있긴 한데 여기 보시면 공구함이라든지 작업대라든지 작업 레이아웃이라든지 이런 것들이 정형화가 돼 있어요.
이태리 장인께서 한 땀 한 땀 만드시는 것 같은데.
아니 근데 우리가 기대하는 모습은 옵티머스가 만드는 걸 기대하고 있는데.
왜 가네수구만 버리냐.
굉장히 장인 분이 고려 총사 만들듯이 만들고 계셔서 뭐 처음이니까 그렇겠죠?
처음이니까 이렇게 하고 있고 일론 머스크 이제 대표님께서도 CEO께서도 이야기하시는 건 장기적으로는 옵티머스가 옵티머스를 생산을 할 거다라는 이야기를 하고 있어서.
살짝 인간 문화재 느낌이야 지금.
그 이제 그 그림들은 분명히 나올 거고요.
근데 요즘 이제 재밌는 이야기들이 많이 들리는 게 이제 공작 기계라고 하는 게 있어요.
아 그래요?
그래서 일본 로봇을 투자한 거예요.
많은 게 없구만.
또 일본 로봇까지 갔어요 자네는?
한악 나무테스코.
한악이 좋은 이유가 이 공작 기계인지 이런 것 때문인데 공작 기계가 요즘 수주 지표가 좀 좋아지고 있어요.
여기 오른쪽 상단 보시면은 yy로 계속 올라가고 있고 이게 이제 왜 올라가냐 하면은 물론 이제 이거는 데이터 센터 때문에 거기 들어가는 냉각 장치나 이런 데 들어가는 부품들 만드는 그런 장비로 공작 기계가 많이 쓰이는데.
특히 또 중국 기업들 쪽으로는 중국 부품사들.
휴먼웨이드 부품사들.
공작 기계를 엄청 사간다라는 이야기들이 일본의 그 공작 기계 협회라든지 기업들에서 나오고 있어요.
그래서 되게 좀 재밌는 포인트다라고 생각을 했던 것 같고.
글자가 좀 작긴 합니다.
근데 이제 스감이라고 하는 회사가 있습니다.
이 회사가 중국 쪽에 좀 노출도가 높은 회사인 것 같은데 이 회사가 여기 보시면은 이제 휴먼웨이드 관련해서 부품 수요가 뭐 늘어나고 있다 이렇게 코멘트를 하고 있고 이 수요가 늘어나서 증설까지도 하고 계신 상황이고.
그리고 오른쪽 투표를 보시면은 매출로 봤을 때 이 기타 매출이 휴먼웨이드가 포함이 되어 있는 내용들.
우상향을 하고 있잖아요.
그래서 약간 이 공작 기계 수요가 늘어나고 있구나.
그 이유가 데이터 센터도 있지만 휴먼웨이드도 영향을 미치고 있구나.
근데 그 휴먼웨이드 뭐 부품 만드는 친구들이 사가는 거니까 부품 만들면은 완제품들도 뭔가 이어지겠구나 이런 생각들을 해볼 수가 있어서 제일 앞단의 시장이 움직이기 시작했다는 점들도 좀 이제 주목해서 봐야 되는 내용이라고 생각을 합니다.
근데 일본이 약간 잘하는 게 이 세밀한 그 관절 도가니 이런 거 잘하잖아요.
엄청 잘하죠.
근데 이제 이거를 공장을 자동화하면은 얘네들이 잘하는 애들이 계속 잘할 거다 이런 얘기가 있잖아요.
이 공작 기계 이런 것들은 일본 기업들이 계속 잘할 거라고 생각을 하고 있고 그리고 뭐 산업용 로봇같이 레거시한 로봇들에서는 일본이 이제 계속 잘할 거라고 생각도 합니다.
중국도 못 따라오나요?
중국도 그러니까 이제 이거는 일본 기업들 입장이기는 해요.
제가 안 그래도 지지난달에 이제 일본 기업들도 가서 만나고 왔었는데 이제 일본 기업들 입장에서 보셨을 때 느끼는 것들은 하이엔드 시장은 우리 거다.
아 그치 그치.
잘해.
뭐 모르겠는데 정밀 가공이나 정말 정확하게 움직여야 되는 부분에 있어서는 중국 기업들도 다 우리 거 쓰고 있어서 봐라 지표로 봐봐라 지금 중국에서 공작 기계 수주가 그럼 왜 올라가냐.
그리고 뭐 산업용 로봇도 보시면은 화낙이나 이런 기업들 지금 중국 쪽에서 매출이나 수주가 엄청 늘어나고 있는 상황이어서 왜 늘어나냐라고 보니까 그 이브이 중국 쪽에서 전기차 생산 늘어나고 이래가지고 이제 거기서 이제 화낙 거 막 사가고 이런 것들 때문에 그런 거여서 일본은 계속 이제 레거시한 것들은 잘하기 때문에 투자의 그런 아이디어라고 생각합니다.
근데 일본 로봇을 너무 잘 아시겠어요.
왜냐면 그때 일본에서 공부하셨다고.
네네네.
거의 일본 사람.
맞죠.
근데 제가 이제 뭐 화낙을 다녔던 건 아니여가지고 잘 모를 수도 있는데.
근데 가시면 일본어로 대화하세요.
일본어로 대화하죠.
우와 우와 어떻게 해요.
일본어로.
오시모씨.
더 더.
더 어려운 말들 쓸면서.
영어 쓰는 사람들은 많은데 일본어 쓰면 신기해요.
아니 신기하잖아요.
아니 왜냐면 일본어를 잘 아는데 일본 로봇 공장에 가.
아니.
근데 일본 로봇 공장에 가.
그럼 뭔가 더욱 고급 정보를 얻을 것 같은데.
그렇긴 하죠.
오히려 또 다 저희가 이야기를 했을 때 일본어로 하면 훨씬 타내게 이야기
해주시긴 합니다.
아니 근데 거기서 얻어온 고급 정보는 이게 뭐 알 텐데.
최근에 일본 기업들 탐방하고 왔을 때.
네 네 로봇도 좋은데 제일 관심이 있었던 건 광이였어요.
광?
일본 광?
광통신 쪽.
제가 담당자는 아니지만 광통신 쪽.
광통신 벨류 체인에서 일본이 엄청 잘하는 거.
아시bereichת.
그러요?
하긴 이런거 세밀한 거 잘할 테니까.
네.
만에 들어가는 소재 이런 것들 일본 애들이 다 독점하고 있어요.
그래서 주가도 엄청 잘 갔고
이익률도 우피마진으로 이거 말해도 되는지는 모르겠지만
광소재 중에서 제일 중요한 웨이퍼가 있는데
그게 거의 우피마진 영업이익률로 30-40% 나올 겁니다.
근데 지금 계속 쇼티지가 있어가지고
더 가격이 올라가고 있어서 더 좋아질 수도 있고
그래서 다시 돌아와가지고
로보티즈라고 하는 회사도 작년도에 유상증자를 많이 하셨죠.
그리고 우즈벡에다가 공장 짓는다고 하시는데
거기에 뭘 사려고 하냐 하면
결국 다 공작기계예요. 보시면
가공장비들
우즈벡이죠?
우즈베키스탄에다가 짓습니다.
거기에 뭐 좋은 게 있습니까?
거기에 땅덩어리들이 많아요.
땅이 넓어요?
땅이 넓고
그리고 사람도 많고
소련의 영향들 때문에 사람들이 근면하신 것도 있으신 것 같고
그리고 중앙아시아 쪽이 자동차 산업 이런 게 되게 발달했다고 하더라고요.
공업 기반도 꽤 있는 상황이어서
싸게
그리고 많이 만들 수 있는 그런 여건이어서
여기다가 투자를 하셨고
공작기계도 이렇게 많이 산다라는 이야기들이어서
공작기계 수요가 늘어날 만하다 이런 내용이었고
뒤에서 제가 로보티즈 이야기도 드릴 텐데
제가 제일 많이 받는 질문 중에 하나가
우즈벡에 진짜 짓는 거 맞냐?
그러니까
왜 하필 우즈벡이냐?
좀 생뚱맞긴 해
물론 아직 제가 짓는 건 눈으로 못 봤어요.
회사한테 이거 한번 가야 된다라고도 이야기를 많이 드리고 있고
부지는 제가 어딘지는 알아냈고
갔다 오시면 저희 코믹스에 한번 나와서
한번 초청해 주시면 나와서
우즈벡 탐방기를 말씀을 드리도록 하겠습니다.
그것도 뒤에서 한번 짧게 설명을 드릴게요.
양산이 움직이고 있고
보스턴다니엘에서도 양산형 설계 채택을 해서 한다.
그리고 맨 오른쪽에 보시면
자동차 공법들을 적용을 한다고 이야기를 해요.
사실 제가 앞에서 공작기계 말씀드렸지만
이거 너무 시간 오래 걸리고 비싸고
그래서 제가 항상 이야기를 하는 거는 찍어내야 된다.
다이캐스팅 이런 공법들이 필요한데
VVS는 그 공법들에 대해서는
그걸 이야기했던 거죠.
이렇게 물구나무 서기해서 성능들을 입증을 했다.
짤한다. 짤한다.
움직였다가 헤드라인이면 안 될 것 같은데요.
움직였고
근데 저 움직임 디테일해요.
왜냐하면 저 액취에이터 현대 모비스가 만들잖아요.
그리고 섬세하게 관절이 꺾여지는 각도가
개다리 춤 추는 거 못 보셨어요?
아니 근데 물구나무 선 거는
저게 위가 다리고 아래가 팔이하고 정의를 하니까
우리가 보기에 물구나무 섰지.
애코파로 서 있는 것 같은데
날카로워.
위가 파리하고 치면
그래서 움직였다 정도로는 안 되고
실전에 어느 정도 투입할 수 있냐
안 움직이면 어떡해요.
향상의 능력을
예리해. 예리해.
조금 더 보여줘야 될 것 같아요.
근데 사실 이게 나중에 영상을
볼륨을 크게 하고 들어보시면
일단 노래가 없어요.
보통 로봇 회사들 영상에 막 뚱뚱뚱뚱한 신나는 노래 많이 나오는데
노래 하나도 없고
그냥 이제 퓨어한 현장 소음만 나오는데
소음이 아무것도 안 들리실 거예요.
아 소음이 없다.
나중에 이 로봇이 물구나무 서기했다가
다리 폈다가 다시
서는 장면들이 있는데
굉장히 소프트하게 서거든요.
이게 진짜 중요한 이 로봇의
하드웨어적인 제어의 움직임이어서
움직였다 해서 끝나지는 않았다
이런 생각도 있고
현대차 팔고 나서 지금 상당히 까칠하셨는데
냉철해졌어요.
그러니까 주주일 때는 이런 거 안 궁금해하더니
한번 내려갔다 다시 가시던가
나도 같이
탑승 기회를 줘라.
탑승 문 열고 가시면
움직여도 대단할 수 있어요.
팔고 나서 예민해졌어요.
그리고 또 한 가지 인플리케이션이 있는 게
보스턴 나르메스에서 최근에 많은 분들이 나가셨어요.
CEO, CPO, CSO, COO
그러니까 C레벨들이 다 나가셨거든요.
여기서 이게 망한 거 아니냐
이렇게 생각도 하시는데
두 가지 말씀드릴 수 있는 거는
이분들이 나가고 나서
양산형 로봇이 움직이는 게 나왔기 때문에
기술 기반은 전혀 흔들리지 않았다는 내용들이고
그리고 시장에서 많이 해석을 하시는 게
이분들이 나감으로써
보스턴 나르메스의
컬러가 달라질 거다.
지금 완전히 연구소 느낌이었지만
이제 진짜 상용화와
양산을 위한 움직임들이 나올 거다라고
또 해석을 하시는 분들도 있어서
사실 이분들이 나가셨던 게
사실 저는 또 되게 재밌는 이슈인 거고
지금 이제 새로 C레벨들이
선임 절차에 들어가 있거든요.
누가 들어온지를 보면
앞으로 또 방향성들이 읽히지 않을까 생각을 해서
좀 기회 주시를 하자.
이런 거 많이 바꾼다.
양산을 막 하는데
중화부가 나갔다는 건
뭔 뉴스 같지는 않은데요.
얘네끼리 또 회사 차리는 거 아니야?
왠지 만들어보고
양산 딱 시키려고 보니까
지분이 얼마 안 남았다.
저는 여기까지죠.
왠지 그럴 수도 있잖아요.
그럴 수도 있죠.
그럴 수도 있고
새로 임명하는 분들을 봐야 될 것 같은데
임명하는 분들을 봐야 되는 게
되게 중요하다.
이게 뭐 진짜
현대차의 등살에 떠밀려서 나간 건지
자발적으로
아 이건 안 되겠다 싶어서 나간 건지
뭐 이런 거 일지는
지켜봐야 되겠지만
그거 보는 것도 하나의 관전 포인트인 거죠.
사실 25페이지는
사실 양산하면
부품 밸류체인이 뜰 수밖에 없거든요.
왜냐하면
그렇죠.
사실 지금 AI 산업에서도 돈 버는 거는
AI 기업들이 아니라
AI 인프라 기업들이잖아요.
반도체 아니면 전력 인프라
사실 로봇도 똑같을 거다.
로봇 기업들이 돈 버는 것보다는
오히려 앞단에서 부품사들이 돈 버는 게
더 빠를 수도 있다고 생각도 하고 있고
맞지 맞지.
사실 정말 냉정하게 봤을 때는
부품 시장에서 누가 잘하냐 했을 때
우리 한국도 잘하고 일본도 잘하지만
중국도 만만치 않게 잘하거든요.
그러니까 중국 잘하잖아.
싸게 잘 만드니까
그러니까 미국이 그걸 알아요.
아 이거 중국 거 너무 많이 썼다가는
나중에 이거 큰일 날 수도 있다.
그래서 지금 정책적으로 엄청 견제를
하려고 법도 만들고 있고
발의도 하고 청문회도 하고
이런저런 이야기들을 하고 계시는
사람들인데
이렇게 하다 보니까 저도 작년에는
이렇게 되면 중국이 밸류체인에서
쫓겨나면 한국이 수혜해보지 않을까
이렇게 되게 나이브하게 생각을 했는데
아니에요?
아니었던 것 같아요.
왜냐하면 지금 모든 로봇 기업들이
다 가격을 이야기하는데
일론 머스크도 2만 달러
유니트리는 만 달러, 천 달러
이렇게 이야기를 하는 상황에서
가격 싸게 만들려면 사실 중국산 부품을
쓸 수밖에 없습니다.
싫든 좋든
너무 싸니까
그래서 이제 물론
장기적으로는 대체가 될 수도 있긴 하겠지만
단기적으로는 중국산을 쓸 수도 있으니까
이거 너무 만약 우리의 장밋빛 미래로 보는 건
조금 리스크가 될 수도 있다.
그래서 이제 우리나라에서 저희가
투자 관점에서 보실 때 중요한 거는
중국 대비해서 조금 그래도 부가가치를 낼 수 있는
좀 고부가가치의 부품들
아니면은
그래도 우리가 중국이랑 좀 비벼서 볼 수 있는
가격 경쟁력을 갖고 있는 기업들
그리고 거기서 양산 능력까지 갖추고 있는
쉽지 않네요.
회사여서 조건이 매우 까다롭다.
근데 거기에 또 개인적으로 이제
따로 투자 의견은 없지만은
부합한다라고 생각을 하는 게
로보티즈라고도 생각을 해서
그래서 로보티즈도 조금 관심 있게 보고 있는
그런 상황이어서
또 그건 또 뒤에서 설명을 드릴 거고요.
그리고 이제 뭐 이건 양산 능력인데
보시면은 지금 중국 기업들
뭐 일본 기업들은 다 거의 100만 대가 넘어갑니다.
감속기나 액취에이터 이런 거 봤을 때
원래 잘하니까
근데 우리나라는 좀 작아요.
SPG가 물론 더 늘릴 수도 있겠죠.
근데 지금 26만 대
뭐 SBB테크가 5만 개에서 장기적으로 20만 개
웅장하게 또 로보티즈가 30만 개에서
200만 대, 300만 대, 500만 대까지
늘린다고 하시니까
근데 이렇게 일본이랑 이렇게 비교를 하다 보니까
중국이랑 우리나라가 잘 하긴 하지만
이 개수에 비해서 주가가 좀 많이 오른 느낌이 좀 드네요.
그렇죠. 그렇죠. 그렇죠.
아주 과대평가가 조금 됐을 수도 있겠다라는
시장의 평가인 걸로 생각을 하고 있습니다.
그만큼 기대가 크니까 또
그리고 또 이제 로봇 부품들인데
이게 도대체 뭔 표냐 하실 수도 있는데
왼쪽으로 색깔들이 좀 진한 게
이 로봇 기업들
로봇 제조사들이 내재화를 하는 아이템
맨 오른쪽으로 갔을 때
그냥 시장에 있는 거 사거나
외주하거나 외부 함락 업체들이랑 만드는
그런 구조여서
결론적으로 저희가 부품을 본다고 하면
물론 액취에이터도 좋고 다 좋지만
사실 결론적으로는 이 로봇 기업들이
터치 못하는 게 사실 좋다고도 생각을 하거든요.
왜냐면 로봇 기업들이 터치하면
싸게 만들라고도 할 수 있고 하니까
오히려 센서라든지 칩이라든지
아니면 아싸리 구조 부품 쪽이
더 매력적일 수 있다는 점들을
참고를 드리고 있습니다.
그래서 앞에서 제가 막 비상장기업들
상장하거나
한다고 말씀드렸는데
센서 기업이 내년에 들어올 거예요.
그래서 AD 로보틱스 이런 기업들도 있으니까
사실 제가 센서 중에서 제일 관심 있게
보고 있는 거는 촉각 센서입니다.
왜냐면 로봇이 작업을 해야 되는데
작업 어떻게 하냐
손으로 조작하는 거잖아요.
근데 조작이 뭐냐 하면
이 물체랑 물리적인 상호작용을 하는 건데
상호작용이라고 하는 게 되게 핵심인 겁니다.
시각으로 보고 하는 것도 중요하지만
손으로 이걸 만져가면서
이게 말랑말랑하고
이게 딱딱하고
이게 어떤 물체고
이런 인지하는 게 되게 중요한 거여서
결국 손에서는
촉각 센서가 매우 중요하고
촉각 센서는 꼭 기억을 해드시면 좋을 것 같다.
이런 내용으로 이야기를 드렸습니다.
그럼요.
길게 들었는데
그러면 중국 기업이 있고요.
일본 기업이 있고요.
미국 기업이 있고요.
한국 기업이 있죠.
그리고 완성품이 있고
부품사가 있습니다.
그러니까 4 곱하기 2죠.
일단 소재는 뺀다고 치고
현재 가장 좀 괜찮고
잘 나가고 있는 쪽이
섹터로 뽑아주신다면
네.
그럼 어느 쪽으로
굉장히 이제
섹터로 뽑아주신다면
어려운 질문을 주셨는데
사실 오히려 이제 유튜브고
굳이 꼭 구내주식의
그 조속한
우리 글로벌로 가니까
우리 글로벌로 가요.
글로벌까지 본다고 하면
사실 개인적으로
제가 일본에서 오래 살아서
그런 건 아니지만
일본이 헤리티지는 확실히 있다.
그래. 일본 로봇이 간다니까.
최근에 막
하모닉 드라이버 시스템 이런 애들이
막 십몇%씩 가고 하는 게
괜히 가는 게 아니거든요.
요즘에 환악 15%씩 올라요.
그 무거운 주식이
맞습니다.
그게 아까 말씀드린
공작기계 이야기도 있고
하지만은 뭐
환악 15%씩 올라요.
환악도 작년부터
엔비디랑 협업하면서
피지컬 AI 하겠다라고
이야기를 했고
하모닉 드라이버 시스템은
글로벌 휴먼웨이드 업체
15개 업체들이
자기한테 와가지고
같이 만들자고
애걸 복걸을 하고 있다고
이야기를 하니까
그래서 결론으로
사구팍 2로 주셨던 내용에서는
1등은
일본 부품
그리고
2등은
한국 부품
왜냐하면 중국은
중국 분들한테
죄송하긴 하지만은
제가 몰라서 그런 걸 수도 있어요.
정보 접근이 정말 안 됩니다.
한국보다도
팩트체크가 안 되고
이야기가 안 돼서
이거는 이제 저희가
내러티브로
중국이 싸게 잘 만드니까
하나보다 이렇게 생각을 할 수 있는데
그 체크가 안 되니까
오히려 조금 이제
안정적으로는 한국 부품이
나왔을 수도 있겠다
라고 생각을 해서
1등은 일본 부품
2등은 이제 한국 부품
완성률은 좀 뒤로 가 있네요.
지금 부품이 먼저 나간다.
맞습니다.
말씀드렸잖아요.
그 AI 시대에서
돈 벌고 있는 게
누가 벌고 있냐
반도체 아니면은
전력 인프라 이런 것들이
돈을 버는 거고
사실 과거에 그
골드러시
황금 시대 때도 돈 벌었던 거는
곡괭이 파는 친구들이
돈을 벌었기 때문에
약간 이제 그런 유사한 성격으로
좀 산업 흐름들을
따라가 봐야 되지 않나
라고 생각을 합니다.
일단 부품 쪽이
좀 이렇게 보이신다.
아 부품
이해씨
네
잠 안 자요?
요즘 주식만 봐?
무슨 일본 기업 종목 이름이
왜 나오는 거야 입에서?
아니 일본 로봇을 제가
나부테스코랑
하나기랑 개별 투자
뿐만 아니고
글로벌 로봇
제펜 로보틱스
그 ETF도 있거든요.
그래서 여러분들
일본 주식은
그 100주식 구매해야 되는 거 아시죠?
그래서 어려우신 분들은
글로벌 로보틱스 ETF를 사시면 됩니다.
그건 한 주만 사셔도 돼요.
동토방에서 배웠어요?
아니 뭐 다 공부한다니까
아 공부한다고?
맞죠?
맞습니다.
100주 단위씩 사야 됩니다.
그러니까
제가 왜냐하면 고품격
그 주식 방송을 하는데
몰라서 언제까지
주린이처럼 할 수 없잖아요.
제가 로봇은 주린이긴 하지만
관심이 개인적으로 많기 때문에
또 여쭤본 거고
오늘 또 부품
또 꿀팁 얻었잖아요.
좋습니다.
오늘 리브
너무나 어려운 얘기
로봇장에 대한
이야기를 한번 들어봤는데요.
우리 니뉴 씨의
공부량에
머리를 탁 치고 갑니다.
아니
공부 좀 하세요 이제.
너무 주식에 관심이 없어.
반도체밖에 몰라가지고
어떡해.
다 알아야지.
자 고품격
주식판 속 주식은 지금
요즘 주식이 너무나 뜨겁습니다.
계속 뜨겁게 갔으면
하는 바람이 있는데
이번 주에 변속이
굉장히 많은 것 같아요.
이중
정상회담도 있고
면중 의장까지 있기 때문에
더 주의 있게 봐야 될 주가
여기까지 생각합니다.
자 오늘은 여기까지 하겠습니다.
여러분 감사합니다.
안녕